fueron todos
el señor carlos osaka conjuga un señor
mexicano hijos de padres japoneses en
una conferencia una vez hice una
metáfora que me gustó mucho él dice que
todas las personas venimos al mundo con
una valija con un maletín con medio
millón que no es medio millón de de oro
ni medio millón en diamantes sino que es
medio millón de horas vida
y conforme nosotros vamos eligiendo
vamos invirtiendo o gastando esas horas
a medida que tomamos decisiones o que
tenemos oportunidades
el tema es que la vida es sumamente
generosa con aquellos que invierten
debidamente su tiempo y sumamente cruel
con aquellos que la malgastan o
directamente dejan pasar esas horas
el tiempo que uno tiene para trabajar
hay que hacerlo con calidad con
responsabilidad afrontar todas esas
responsabilidades debidamente
pero el tiempo de ocio es muy importante
en una persona es salud y lo que
elegimos hacer en ese tiempo de ocio es
lo que va a ser la diferencia ahí es
donde aparecen las aficiones los hobbies
los más llamados pasatiempos los hobbies
son cosas que uno hace simplemente
porque le gusta hacerlo no tiene otra
función de la pasión hacerlo les encanta
y si nosotros podemos compartir esa
afición con alguien con un ser querido
es todavía mucho más placentero de
alguna manera lo que se trata es de
vencer algo que llama procrastinación
que es la acción de un hombre de una
persona por postergar hacer algún
trabajo o alguna cosa que requiere algún
esfuerzo físico algún esfuerzo psíquico
algún estrés una concentración y
reemplazarla por otra acción mucho más
irrelevante como estar sentado mirando
televisión o repasando las redes
sociales o mirando internet que no está
mal hacerlo pero en su tiempo justo en
su medida justa
nosotros yo en particular no nos
dedicamos a hacer cerveza hace más de 15
años y tengo el gran privilegio de
compartir esa afición con mi padre que
tiene 85 años y mi hijo que tiene 18
años y después se suman en otro momento
más placentero el envasado y demás mis
hijas mi esposa y de alguna manera
termina siendo algo familiar es un
tiempo que nosotros aprovechamos para
estar juntos
e
charlamos recordamos viejas anécdotas
compartimos un momento en el proceso que
no hay que hacer gran cosa hay que
esperar que algo se termine entonces es
un tiempo que estamos compartiendo algo
que nos gusta y eso es muy importante en
las personas compartir estar juntos y al
punto que la fis realmente se desdibuja
no importa si estás haciendo cerveza
tejiendo escarpines pintando cuadros o
haciéndolo modelismo lo importante es
aprovechar ese tiempo de ocio con una
afición con algo importante
a medida que uno batiendo aficiones
seguramente se va a encontrar con gente
y grupo de gente que comparte esas ideas
y que no solo se van a enriquecer
técnicamente sino que van a ser amigos
van a hacerse amigos cosas que uno se
reúne para charlar de algo que les guste
en común y a veces eso no es tan simple
de disfrutar
por supuesto que los jóvenes las
aficiones
no tiene nada que ver con ser
emprendedores no tiene nada que ver la
afición no soporta ningún una fórmula
financiera no se hace
pensando en ser un emprendedor y luego
una afición si un hobby se transforma en
un emprendedurismo es excelente todo el
mundo tiene derecho a ganarse su dealer
ilio pero una afición nace por el simple
hecho de que a uno le gusta hacerlo no
tiene otra ambición
déjenme contarles dos historias
dos historias cercanas cuando yo era
chico
las familias se visitaban y nosotros
fuimos a visitar a un pariente que
quedaba lejos cada dos o tres años nos
visitábamos y era la casa del tío ya con
un saco formento se llamaba
él tenía una afición que estaba
orgulloso de tenerla que era la de
fabricar vino
y estaba orgulloso porque de alguna
manera él había heredado eso en la
familia y seguía con esa tradición
así que en un viaje que fuimos luego de
las primeras charlas de quien había
nacido en la familia a quien se había
casado quien había muerto yo veo que
metió ya colegas en europa una seña
media cómplice se levantan y se van para
el patio
atrás de eso así que nos llevan a un
lugar que es una
un galponcito del fondo una piecita un
lugar lúgubre oscuro pero que él se
desenvolvía bien porque era su lugar
abre una ventanita entre un poquito de
luz
saca con un artificio y me sirve
tres copas de vino
ensayamos un brindis
y la tomamos y lo probamos
ese vino era
a quiero yo era realmente duro de tomar
era una cosa aspira
pero la carga de 28 kos contento la
felicidad porque había hecho algo que lo
compartía con alguien querido eso no
tiene precio no y bueno yo tuve un
poquito de eso es tremendo y cuando nos
llevamos metió le da a mi papá una
botellita envuelta en papel de diario
con un amor una calidez hasta dictó con
un hilito blanco esos de algodón es un
moñito y se le entrega como un gran
obsequio
eso es el orgullo de hacer algo porque
te gusta ni siquiera tenéis que ser el
mejor ni ser bueno ni ser el número 1
hacerlo porque uno quiere
la otra anécdota la otra historia es un
poco más cercana es de mi abuelo mi
abuelo emilio un hombre de campo hijo de
inmigrantes afincados aquí entre alemán
y ataliva
un tipo duro acostumbrado a los trabajos
del campo al clima es la época del orden
y a mano
pero estando tan sensibles cuando nací
mi madre
como no puede ser de otra manera a la
madrugada de un día de tormenta tremenda
con refuse hilos y vientos y ellos
vivían solitos en la casa así que mi
abuelo tuvo que ayudarla mi abuela atrae
mi mano al mundo acomodo el cordón
umbilical se la pone sobre el regazo y
sale a caballo aunque a la partera que
la trae nada bueno ese tipo tan duro y
tan sensible tenía su afición tenía su
joven desde que yo me acuerdo su afición
era trabajar en cuero así implementos de
cuero
todo lo que tenga que ver con
herramientas de campo lazo gonzález
estriberas riendas todas cosas brutas
rudas pero con una calidad de trabajo
con una concentración y el terminaba de
hacer todo su trabajo de campo que no
era liviano cuando volvía se utilizaba
iba a su galponcito cruzando el patio
donde tenía todas sus cosas y ahí se
concentraba por horas y era algo que le
encanta
ahora imagínense que el cuero no lo va a
comprar en un supermercado oa un negocio
había que rebuscárselas así que él le
avisaban los vecinos le decía en tal
lugar sacrifica un animal para consumo o
un animal nació muerto un postre si tuvo
que sacrificar entonces iba a juntar su
cuero y así es un verano que yo estaba
con ellos pasamos varios veranos
y avisa de una posibilidad de un cuerpo
así que no fuimos con el vecino
y la verdad que ir a buscar fue
prácticamente una excusa porque él
aprovechó para charlar con su vecino que
hace rato que no lo veía aprovechan
también hablar el dialecto en piamonte
es que también le gustaba
yo le que unas macetas vainillas de que
la señora me había dado en el horno
media fritas visualmente pero muy rica
yo no voy a olvidarme los ricas jamás
volvió a probar una masita vanidad es
tan rica como esa y no volvimos y
terminó siendo una aventura una aventura
que no hubiéramos vivido así es no vi la
teoría de esa ficción y cuando uno tiene
algo y trabaja algo que es bueno van
ocurriendo otras cosas
un día aparece un señor señor de campo
un criollo a comprarle las cosas a mi
abuela entonces le prepara
lo que necesitaba burlarse un revés que
esto lo otro y luego de una pequeña
negociación le pagan
y se va cuando se va yo lo increpó a mi
abuelo y luego pero abuelo porque le
cobras te tampoco porque vende es eso
tan barato con tanto trabajo que te
cuesta hacerlo
él me responde dos cosas la primera me
dice lo que pasa que el hombre lo
necesitaba lo necesitaba para trabajar y
lo segundo me dice y además yo ya me
divertí bastante mientras lo hacía
por supuesto que yo de chicos no no
entendí lo que me quiso decir
y con los años y con la vida aprendí
creo haber interpretado lo que él me
dijo lo primero lo necesitaba para
trabajar no creo que haya algo que te
haga sentir más orgulloso una persona
que fabricará algo hacer algo
y venderlo regalarlo donarlo prestarlo a
alguien que sabe lo que está recibiendo
que lo va a usar para lo cual fue
concebida y que lo va a exigir es el
ayuda ser exigido para lo que fue hecho
y eso es lo que te hacía sentir
orgullosa y lo segundo ya nos divertimos
bastante mente lo hacíamos creo que la
filosofía de un joven
el hecho de hacerlo y de solamente
porque uno le gusta y porque uno lo
quiere hacer
bien deportivamente
nadie se levanta una mañana y dice a ver
hoy me voy a dedicar a una afición a
buscar un juego me voy a hacer una lista
de hobby voy a empezar la verdad que eso
no ocurre así imagínense que para cada
cosa uno necesita de herramientas
equipos técnica
más o menos complicada en función a lo
que quiera dedicarse hay herramientas
que son específicas para madera otra que
son específicas para electricista para
soldadores a mí me gusta pensar que las
aficiones se encuentra
a veces uno mira algo de algo tiene en
la mano algo escucha hereda un guión
dentro de la familia que tal pariente se
dedicaba a hacer tal cosa y a partir de
ahí comienza como a gestarse con un amor
y de a poquito uno empieza a preguntar y
a dedicarse y adjuntar y fabricar
herramientas y demás
vamos a comprar mil excusas que el
dinero que el tiempo que nuestra agenda
que está apretada pero créanme que en
una agenda es tan importante una reunión
como el tiempo de descanso el tiempo de
ocio y elegir sabiamente qué hacer en
ese tiempo de ocio
yo
deseo para todos ustedes que sus
aficiones y sus hobbies los encuentren
dependerá de ustedes reconocerlas
si ya saben a qué le gustaría dedicarse
si sabes lo que abriga su corazón
arranca empieza y aprovecha en ese
tiempo que con el que vinimos
no dejen que todos se lo cuenten hay
cosas que hay que vivirlas
recuerden como dijo albert eisntein no
todo lo que puede contar se cuenta y no
todo lo que cuenta puede contarse
hay que vivirlo con calidad y usen el
tiempo de su maletín muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]